marie claire blais bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci surtout
que vous n'aimez pas particulièrement
les entrevues à la caméra d'ailleurs
pourquoi c'est une intimité
marie claire blais votre série soit fait
votre dernier roman une réunion près de
la mer sont considérés comme espèce
d'ovni dans l'univers littéraire
c'est comme ça que vous le voyez aussi
mais c'est un long travail en tt c'est
un acharnement mais en même temps c'est
c'est merveilleux de pouvoir parler de
plus et être là parce que je lis je les
entends comme si c'était une musique là
j'entends leurs bois je vois là je vois
le visage les vois je les sens venir
mais aussi scellier aurel
allez portrait réel et mais en même
temps comme ce sont des voix intérieure
que tu t'es tu deviennes entendu qu'on
en tant qu'homme et à travers ces voix
là même même quand c'est là dans la
grande détresse
il ya toujours un champ derrière un
champ un champ joie eu quand même la
reconnaissance de vivre peut-être je
prends mon mal clair les pages 75 vous
écrivez je vous souhaite cet habit la
compassion des femmes les unes envers
les autres qui avait produit cette
fièvre d'une plus grande équité
cette compassion c'est ce qui se passe
présentement dans tout le débat que je
crois c'est une compassion résistante
mais elle est là elle est présente
comment vous le voyez ce débat je pense
que
les formes sont très résistantes elles
sont très fortes en ce moment et il faut
qu'elle le demeure mais aussi en en ce
moment c'est une période dans ces livres
là en tout cas où on est content de
retrouver la solidarité est maintenant
temps de se retrouver en quelque sorte
au sourire dans votre nouveau roman il
ya une scène très poignante où un fils
et a lâché à son père l'instant un
immigrant illégal
ces genres de 5 que vous voyez souvent
aux états unis dont vous habitez
malheureusement ne les voyons partout
nous ne sommes témoins de ces cinq
partout et cette scène est très très
douloureuse pour moi mais je pense que
si on ne fait pas attention cette scène
du père préfère h et à son fils du fils
souvent arrachait son père si on ne fait
pas attention on va vraiment continuer
dans cette mauvaise voie là ouais si sa
mère il la reconnaît elle ne vient pas
vers lui encore il pourrait croire
qu'elle a abandonné évidemment préparant
cette entrevue j'étais tout repensé à ma
première lecture d'un de vos oeuvres une
saison dans la vie d'emmanuel fait déjà
50 ans vous avez remporté le prix
médicis pour son mal parce qu'il vous
arrive d'y repenser non je suis très
proche d'une saison dans la vidéo
c'est quand même ça pourrait se passer
en chine au brésil par tous et je suis
très sensible ces mêmes c'est une oeuvre
de jeunesse une saison dans la vie d'un
homme elle appartient un temps comment
dire c'est écrit très jeune
c'était mon naturel de vivre un compris
qu il n'en souffrent pas autant qu'on
pense je crois je doive parler de
légende chambre qui nous a quittés il ya
déjà plusieurs mois de cela en 2017
quels souvenirs gardez-vous de lui très
tendre très tendre et et de séparation
aussi parce que
le fait de vivre aux états unis je vais
un peu perdu et mais nous avons toujours
une longue correspondance écrite mais
évidemment nous sommes tous bien triste
comment expliquez-vous qui va cesser
d'écrire après son roman gros je me
demande si qu'elle une réticence il a
éprouvé quelques douleurs
c'est très secret 1 mais enfin son
oeuvre est là mais c'est tout ce qui
compte
en fait vous fait même appel à la
mémoire oui mais un appel à la qualité
aussi
on doit conserver les oeuvres de nos
écrivains comme gilbert maroc claire
martin aime ce maillot il ya plein
d'écrivains qu'on a
jean vas-y grandjean basique on a laissé
on est derrière je pense qu'on va le
faire à l'avenir mais encore c'est trop
tard à mon avis il faudrait que tous ces
écrivains reviennent sur notre scène
intérêts absolument
mais qu'est ce qui vous attend
maintenant après la série soir même pour
le moment toi trois autres livres sur
lequel je travaille ma coeur même si
vous êtes heu plaisait plus
[Musique]